how do you feel about like just kind of  like the way tic tocs kind of changing  the way  i mean it's really changing music a  little bit yeah it is have you had like  a tick tock moment yet where like you  maybe i busted top side of the head man  lottery was tit-top that was all  tick-tock yeah that [ __ ] was i was the  one that opened the flood was that on  the purpose like did you put something  it just happened it happened organically  you know what i'm saying and and  you know the the the downside of it i  didn't really get the benefits  financially from that because it was  some new [ __ ] yeah plus you don't right  yeah yeah cause that was a that was like  a year and a half ago yeah that was just  some some some new [ __ ] so you know i  didn't really get see the full  but  yeah man like we said that we said the  blueprint do you know we wanna we won a  cleo award for that